بعد الان من جبل الزيتون في القدس مراسله
الجزيره جيفارا البديري لراس تطورات
الموقف من القدس بعد اقتحام قوات الاحتلال
للمسجد الاقصى او المسجد القبدي تحديدا
واعتدائها على المصلين والمعتكفين فيه
بعد ليله عصيبه جدا ومشاهد قال
الفلسطينيون انها لا توصف بكل الكلمات
الان الهدوء الحذر يسود كافه انحاء القدس
وتحديدا في داخل المسجد الاقصى المبارك
اقل من نصف ساعه ويتم اغلاق باب المغاربه
الذي منه يدخل
المستوطنون فيما تعرف بالزياره الصباحيه
وبالطبع عمليات الاقتحامات اليوميه حتى
هذه الساعه دخل الى داخل المسجد الاقصى
المبارك
مستوطنا ولكن ايضا الشرطه الاسرائيليه
قالت انها قامت باعتقال مستوطنين متطرفين
من المتعصبين كانوا يحملون جديا وكانوا
وكانوا يريدان ادخاله الى داخل المسجد
الاقصى المبارك
يعني هو تدنيس للمسجد و ذبحه كقربان وفق
المعتقدات اليهوديه وهذا ما حذر منه كافه
الائمه ورجال الدين وايضا
عديده من المسؤولين الفلسطينيين بان ادخال
القرابين الى داخل المسجد الاقصى المبارك
كما حدث العام الماضي وتم منع ذلك من قبل
الحكومه الاسرائيليه مجرد ادخال هذه
القرابين فان الوضع كله بمجمله ساء ينفجر
الان سنتطرق ايضا الى وضع المعتقلين في
هذا المشهد الذي رايناه على كل الشاشات
كيف تم اعتقال الفلسطينيين اكثر من 450
فلسطينيا الكثير منهم من الفتيه ما اكده
لنا قبل قليل احد هؤلاء
المعتقلين هو فتى في الراء 15 من العمر تم
الافراج عنه اكد لنا بان من يفرج عنه يحصل
على قرار بالابعاد عن البلده القديمه
والمسجد الاقصى المبارك على الاقل لمده
اسبوع وهذا العقاب قابل للتجديد ومن يخالف
يغرب حتى من هم ايضا من سكان البلده
القديمه سيضطرون للمبيت في الخارج ولكن
ايضا ما اكدته احدى المحاميات التي ترافق
المعتقلين في مراكز التحقيق والتوقيف تؤكد
بان الكثير من المعتقلين وضعهم صعب
يحتاجون الى تدخل طبي عاجل ما اكده لنا
الفتى ايضا بان قوات الاحتلال عندما
اعتقلتهم وقامت بتكبيلهم داخل المسجد
الاقصى المبارك بعد
ضربهم والتنكيل بهم جلسوا واجبروا على
الجلوس على الركبتين لا اكثر من اربع
ساعات في البرد وايضا كل من يحاول من
التعب ان يرفع راسه كان عدد من الجنود
يقومون
ضربه بالهروات على منطقه الراس راينا ايضا
عدد من هؤلاء المعتقلين وقد خرجوا بعد
الافراج عنهم وهناك ضمادات على
الراس واثار لدماء وبالتالي الخشيه ايضا
مما هو قادم خاصه ان الليله يبدا عيد
الفصح اليهودي وهذا ما سنبقى في متابعته
شكرا لك لمن جبل الزيتون في القدس مراسله
الجزيره جيفارا البديري